it's Thursday so you know what that
means
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
welcome to this week's Theory Thursday
my segment where I pick theories that
you all submitted to be entered in a
monthly contest each week you will vote
on a winner and at the end of the month
you will vote for your overall favorite
theory right now the monthly winner will
receive an IMAX gift card so you and a
friend can go see the latest Marvel
movie last week's winner was Theory
number four from Austin Green Congrats
Austin you are now entered in the pool
of champions this week we have some
amazing theories some short some long
some extremely detailed so let's just
jump right into it our first theory
today comes from casera Calzada and
casera says what if dr. Strange's whole
use of the word end game was actually a
hint for Tony because a lot of us even
me forgot that dr. strange was not the
first person to use the term end game it
was actually Tony an age of Ultron there
that's that's saying again how are you
guys planning on beating
together
we'll lose
and we'll do that together too kisara
goes on to say and as we all know they
were no longer the Avengers after Civil
War so let's say that Tony remembers
Doctor Strange mentioned in-game to him
and he goes back whether in time with
the quantum realm or just remembers
while trying to find the deeper meaning
to dr. Strange's words and he happens
upon the conversation with Stephen his
self and they realized that they have to
fight together to stop Thanos Kucera
also says that also if you remember in
the in-game trailer when Marvel Studios
turns to dust that dust becomes the a
symbol for Avengers and maybe that's
hinting towards the Avengers assembling
which ties into the leak that there's a
scene with 40-plus characters in it in
the movie so I definitely have to agree
that Doctor Strange set in game for a
very specific reason even Kevin Feige
president of Marvel Studios said in an
interview that Doctor Strange said in
game for a very specific reason because
they knew that's what the title would be
for Avengers for Avengers end game so
since he said it for a very specific
reason it's obviously going to play some
importance in Avengers end game plus
it's the name of the title so Doctor
Strange could have very well been
hinting to Tony about something and I
also have to agree that the key to
defeating Thanos is the Avengers doing
it together if time travel is involved I
think they will go back to the time of
Civil War and keep the Avengers from
breaking up that way when Thanos comes
the Avengers will all be together and
can fight him together
so that's theory number 1 on to theory
number two theory number two comes from
Zenith meta a fifteen-year-old from
India Zenith says that we know an
Avengers for there will be time travel
remaining heroes will travel back in
time to defeat Thanos from starting the
quest of the Infinity stones and defeat
him in the past so instead of fighting
Thanos as he is right now they'll go
back in time and try to defeat him
before he gathers all of the Infinity
stones Zenith goes on to say that after
the Avengers defeat Thanos they will end
up creating a new timeline where events
of Infinity Ward never happened and no
one will remember anything except for
the heroes that went back in time and
fought Thanos Zenith says that during
this battle against Thanos some of the
Avengers will die specifically Thor and
Iron Man this theory has proved from the
far from home tree
we know that in the end of infinity war
50% of the population is dead but in the
far from home trailer everything seems
normal
this is due to the new timeline where
the events of infinity war never
happened but Tony Stark is dead Xena
says that this is why happy is with Aunt
May and Peter and taking care of Peter
as Tony did before and this is also why
Peter doesn't have the iron spider suit
in the far from home trailer because the
events of infinity war never happened so
Peter never got the iron spider suit
this theory does have some merit to it
because it does seem like everything is
just completely normal in spider-man far
from home and if the Avengers do go back
in time and keep Thanos from getting the
Infinity stones that will drastically
affect the future and depending on how
you view time everything they do could
definitely create a new timeline one
where the snap never happened remember
Kevin Feige president of Marvel Studios
said that spider-man far from home takes
place after the events of Avengers
endgame but if Avengers endgame creates
a new timeline then that new timeline
technically takes place after the events
of Avengers endgame so it could very
well be possible and that's it for
Theory number 2 on to theory number
three Theory number three comes from
Samuel 15 years old from Puerto Rico and
his friend Sebastian Samuel has a theory
on how he thinks Avengers in games going
to go down he says that the movie will
start off with Thanos on Titan 2
watching the Sun Rise on a grateful
universe it'll then cut to the Avengers
facility where some of the Avengers such
as rocky and Rhodey will have left to go
search for some of the heroes that may
have survived the snap Steve and Natasha
are figuring things out while banner is
looking at the missing heroes we then
cut to ant-man who is stuck inside of
the quantum realm who gets out of the
quantum realm thanks to the help of one
of his aunts when he gets out he sees
the dust on the floor but ignores it and
gets in his van to go search for people
when he's driving he doesn't see anybody
and when he can't find anybody that he
knows he gets worried and goes to the
Avengers
Porter's and that's where we see the
scene with him in the Avengers endgame
trailer they explained to Scott
everything that happened and Scott
realizes that the ashes were from Hank
Janet and hope that he freaks out
wondering about his daughter and he
starts asking about all the other heroes
spider-man Wanda Bucky and ask where
Tony is we see Steve thinking about Tony
and it cuts to Tony and nebula on the
Benatar
they've already tracked earth but don't
have enough fuel to get there and Tony
is about to die Tony finishes his
message to pepper and nebula asks about
pepper and they get to know each other
and then Captain Marvel shows up and the
two of them explain who they are and
what exactly happened with Thanos then
Captain Marvel being afraid of what
happened to Nick Fury pushes them to
earth to the Avengers facility The
Avengers reunite and Tony reunites with
pepper and then Captain Marvel starts
talking about time travel and how she
can do it then Scott remembers what
Janet said about the time vortexes in
the quantum room
Tony and Scott then work on quantum
realm suits to go inside of the quantum
realm to collect time loop fragments
they are successful and they end up
designing suits to use the time loop
fragments to be able to travel through
time they then talk about a plan to go
back in time and collect the Infinity
stones that way the Infinity stones that
Thanos has currently disappeared then
the Avengers break off into separate
missions ant-man Captain America and
Iron Man go back to 2012 and get the
mine stone from Loki's scepter in the
current time Natasha sees the news and
sees that people are dead in the streets
of Japan with arrows in their backs she
knows it's clinched so she goes to Japan
when she finds him she says this isn't
you I can help you we're family
Clint finishes the conversation by
taking off his mask turns around and
says I don't have one then they go back
to the Avengers HQ Scott Steve and Tony
get back and Tony says he needs to go
back to get the tesseract and Thor says
that he'll go get the reality stone Tony
throws on a shield uniform and goes back
to 2012 and gets the tesseract Thor goes
back in time to where he kills Malekith
and gets the reality stone but he also
sees himself from the past gives himself
a little chuckle and takes meal near
from him Thor then returns with the
reality stones Stormbreaker and mule
near Thor then remembers when he met dr.
strange so he goes back in time to talk
to him dr. strange realizes that the
fate of the universe depends on him
giving the time stone to Thor so he
gives it to him
or thing goes to nineveh leer but
doesn't find Eitri but he does take the
Infinity Gauntlet prototype he comes
back and gives it to Tony and Tony makes
a new suit called the infinity suit
Natasha and Clint come back and Clint
talks to Captain Marvel about the
scrolls nebula then says that she can go
back in time and get the Power Stone so
she goes back in time and takes it from
Gamora and quill she gets back and she
explains the soul stone to the Avengers
and the Avengers decide that they will
not sacrifice another life to retrieve
it but they have five stones and prepare
for battle they go back in time to where
Wanda blows up the mine stone and right
when Thanos is about to reverse time the
Avengers show up Dennis is confused so
he uses the space stone to teleport but
Tony uses the mine stone to read his
mind so they quickly follow Thanos to
his planet they're famous has prepared
an army with the reality stone and has
used the soul stone to bring back to
Black Order
The Avengers fight in Captain America
ends up using mule near the Avengers end
up defeating Thanos and they use the
stones to undo the snap and destroy the
stolen stones and ven Tony and Steve
rest watching the Sun Rise on a grateful
universe so that's how Avengers in game
could go down from Samuel and I think
there are a lot of elements in this
theory that could actually happen in the
movie specifically the Avengers going
back in time to collect the Infinity
stones and Tony start designing an
infinity suit
so that's theory number 3 on to number 4
theory number 4 comes from Conor Fenwick
and Conor's theory involves the even
bigger threat that has been mentioned to
come in Avengers endgame if you're not
familiar with the bigger threat it was
mentioned in a toy leaked description
that we got that the Avengers would face
off against an even bigger threat and
then in the book fan oohs Titan consumed
which connects directly to the MCU it
was again stated that there would be an
even bigger threat in Avengers endgame
Connor states that because Thanos
completed his plan to collect all of the
Infinity stones and wipe out 50% of all
living beings and he completed his
destiny eternity shows up he shows up
because Thanos has been tampering with
space-time and reality and becomes a
villain for Thanos and this actually
becomes a bit of an advantage for the
remaining Avengers because eternity is
on their side this actually happens in
the comics it
he shows up and goes head-to-head with
vanos but unfortunately since Thanos has
the Infinity Gauntlet he has the power
to control everything and anything
so Thanos ends up defeating eternity and
there was actually an early plot leak
that said eternity actually shows up
maybe eternity knows that he can't take
on Thanos while he has the Infinity
Gauntlet but he can help the Avengers
that's something I would love to see
happen and we do know that Marvel is
planning on taking phase 4 into the
cosmos so maybe eternity could be a good
way to do that so that's theory number 4
and onto the final theory number 5
number 5 comes from Ryan Vetter and
Ryan's theory is based off of Captain
America and the Avengers endgame trailer
Ryan says that the reason we see Captain
America in his stealth suit in the
Avengers in-game trailer and the reason
we see him in his original Avengers suit
in some leaked photos is because he's
wearing these suits to blend in with the
different time periods that he travels
to when they go back in time this is
also the reason that he shaves his beard
and changes his hair and this is also
the reason that we see him glancing at
the picture of Peggy he knows he's going
back in time to where he can actually
see her again and he says that maybe at
the end he will finally get his dance
with Peggy which would be a great
closing scene for Kat in the MCU I do
have to agree that if the Avengers do go
back in time they'll have to blend in
somehow besides changing the exact
events that they plan on changing to
defeat Thanos they don't want to affect
anything else because that could affect
the future so they definitely don't want
anybody seeing them and realizes that
they're from the future and I do think
the Avengers will each have to go back
in time to periods that meant a great
deal to them and obviously Captain
America will have to go back and see
Peggy if this is the case and we do see
him looking at the picture of her so
there's a good chance that this could
happen so that's it for this week's five
theories let's do a quick recap theory
number one was that dr. strange said
in-game as a hint to Tony and the
Avengers we'll have to fight together if
they want to stand a chance to defeat
Thanos theory number two states that the
Avengers will go back in time to defeat
Thanos and when they do they will create
a new timeline where the snap never
happened and this is why in the
spider-man far from home trailer
everything seems completely normal
number three is a theory on how of
in game will happen the Avengers will go
on separate missions to collect five
Infinity stones and fight against Thanos
when he has five Infinity stones number
four is that the bigger threat that is
coming is actually eternity and eternity
will be on the Avengers side and number
five is that the reason we see Captain
America in different suits is because
he's blending in with the different time
periods that he will travel back to and
at the end he finally gets his dance
with Peggy so that's it for Theory
Thursday this week don't forget to vote
on which theory you like the most if you
have a theory of your own and want to
submit it for a chance to end up on
Theory Thursday you can submit it to
cosmic Theory Thursdays at gmail.com the
instructions for Theory Thursdays are in
the description down below let me know
what you thought about all of these
amazing theories this week and I'll see
you next Thursday for the next episode
of Theory Thursdays be sure to subscribe
to my channel so you can stay up to date
on everything Marvel DC and superhero
related and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]